let's start by discussing what the key
word this is for this is an identifier
that gets a value bound to it much like
a variable but instead of identifying
the values explicitly in your code this
gets bound to the correct object
automatically now mostly the rules for
how the interpreter determines what the
correct binding is resemble the rules
for positional function parameters the
differences between positional function
parameters and the keyword this are
designed to support your intuition about
which object should be focal when you're
invoking a method or a constructor there
are a lot of misconceptions out there so
let's clear them up by going through a
list of the things that the keyword this
specifically won't be bound to